is Eva Mobley underrated we've brought
in the tallest Defender we got and the
coldest
welcome to underrated the only show that
allows your favorite professional
athlete to improve their video game
rating today the first year Phenom Evan
Mobley of the Cleveland Cavaliers
foreign
[Music]
the first time you saw yourself in 2K
what do you remember when it was that
was cool uh when I first came to the
league we got an Xbox turned it on yeah
I played it was dope seeing myself
there's one rating that annoys me for
you it's the post fave yeah they got you
at a 62. I think we got two I think we
gotta bump that up for sure yes yeah who
would you go to if you had to bump
something like that up uh my boy Ronnie
2K he's here yes sir let's get him in
the building
foreign
pretty good well we have obstacles so
that you can see enough to make a change
that's why I'm here you ready to go yes
sir
let's do this yo
[Music]
Evan here's what we're gonna do we got
you on the Block but we need obstacles
they're going to get harder as they go
and we need you to hit about four out of
five I wish we had like an NBA player
here yeah that would be nice one that
might take it a little personal might
one might they have it has a vested
interesting to do would you even say
it's familial let's bring in Isaiah
Mobley
[Music]
[Applause]
coming out of USC he knows all of Evan's
moves you've seen it on the driveway
growing up definitely I need you to stop
them
or at least make it hard definitely can
do that all right Isaiah Mobley
defending Evan Mobley post fate he's a
62. let's see what you got whenever
you're ready
no such thing as brotherly love
yes sir
nothing but one for one
Isaiah is a good Defender yeah I think
we need to get a little bit more
difficult okay
[Music]
yeah this visual is amazing for me oh
he's he's at his arms like Evan's one of
the tallest guys I've ever been around
and this dude is like freakish all right
so I want you to kind of bash Fade Away
real fade away let's go two for two
whenever you're ready don't hurt him he
flip
here it is take that slim Reaper he
doesn't want to use batboard he's just
going straight for the net yes
it's still too easy for you
I want now Slim Reaper and your brother
Isaiah double team create separation and
if you can swish it like you've been
doing that would be amazing
double team he goes away from his
brother
that's what makes a rating so now he
goes left goes left and right it's both
with the double team I think we need to
get more difficult yeah I'm impressed
but uh let's turn it up
we're three for three we brought in the
tallest Defender we got and the coldest
and what do we lovingly call him
snowball snowball
can't even see create some separation
fade away if you hit it beautiful
three for three whenever you're ready
[Music]
he's real good
[Music]
one two three four clean yeah ready at
the four out of five yeah he's a 62. we
know his ratings are going up from last
year after what he showed yes but did he
show enough today for that post Fade to
go up from a 62. I'm glad it's something
that we don't see all the time because I
got to see it in person and over some
monstrous Defenders look pretty good I
think I think that's got to be looked up
was he underrated as a post fate yes
I think he's underrated is that enough
for you yeah as long as it goes up as
long as it goes up I was like
yes let's go Evan Mobley underrated a
man
[Music]